all right let's talk about uh let's talk
about bitcoin a little bit i've been
getting
tons of emails from people saying david
we know you have the bitcoin
what are you doing it crashed have you
sold what's the price going to be
what do you think is going i have
absolutely no idea
and knowing does not affect my plan
whatsoever
why well i'll explain to you why but
first let's talk a little bit about
what's been going on
on the one hand we have seen bitcoin
fall
significantly from its highs a few
months ago
um significant declines not only in
bitcoin but in some other
cryptocurrencies as well and there are
now
two schools of thought one school of
thought is this is the beginning
of these coins becoming completely and
totally
worthless it's just a decline it's never
going back to where it was
it's over get out while you can the
other side is
hey you know what this is just another
lull and
if you zoom out this is the pattern up a
lot down
up a lot down and it's going to go back
up i'm going to tell you
my perspective on this momentarily i do
want to mention
this video was sponsored by policy
genius if someone relies on you for
financial support could be a child could
be a parent business partner
you should have your life insurance in
order it's typically pretty affordable
you get a big sense of relief and
comfort when you put it in place you
know people in
your life are covered but shopping for
life insurance is not fun
i actually interned in the field of life
insurance it's not
fun to shop for it you don't know what
you need how much what you should pay
etc
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
in one place you could save thirteen
hundred dollars or more per year on life
insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies i went on myself
it took two minutes you work out how
much coverage you need
you get quotes and they handle the
paperwork at policy genius
it's fast it's easy they've got
thousands of five star reviews on google
and trustpilot all right so
policygenius.com david pakman show
link is underneath this video when it
comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right with policy
genius
now back to bitcoin do i think that
this is the beginning of the end for
bitcoin or do i think that this
is maybe the end of the beginning the
argument
that things look great for bitcoin is
roughly the following
uh there's a limited supply and over
time
more and more people are going to be
wanting to have some
bitcoin and because the supply is
limited the price
is going to go up in addition another
argument i'm hearing is
there was a big drop but now it's steady
this is the new baseline of support
as some technical analysts say about
bitcoin and my answer is
i have absolutely no idea
and i don't need to know my advice
to myself from the beginning has been
this is not financial advice for anybody
else i'm merely giving you my thought
process
my uh belief has been bitcoin
seems quote legit enough at this point
that i think it is sensible as part of i
uh as part of a diversification
uh sort of plan to hold some amount of
bitcoin
knowing that it is highly speculative
now i've been in bitcoin
since uh 20 2015.
and at this point my bitcoin has gone up
so many times i've sold 10 15 percent
tranches of it over the last many years
at this point i'm essentially playing
with the house's money
and i don't pretend to know whether it
will go to zero or not
it really could go to zero but the point
is
don't put in more money to
cryptocurrency
than you could afford to lose altogether
my
level of risk tolerance is that i
probably don't want to go in with more
than
three to five if you have a lot higher
risk tolerance
five to seven percent of your net assets
i never went in with more than that
since the beginning now obviously as it
grew
it became more and then i would sell
down and out of it but
i don't know what's going to happen in a
year bitcoin could be at a hundred
thousand dollars
or it could be at a hundred dollars i
have no idea
my plan doesn't depend on knowing and
that's the most
important thing i am curious however
to hear from you do you have a
perspective i know that there are some
crypto enthusiasts in our audience
and i know that there are crypto doom
and gloomers in our audience
i'd be interested in hearing from all of
you what do you think the current
stagnation of the bitcoin price means
i don't pretend to know and i don't feel
i need to know
because i'm just holding at this point
to see what happens and it may be worth
a lot or it
may be worth nothing at some point in
time let me know your thoughts in the
comments